[Music]
yesterday donald trump released a video
challenge to president obama saying that
if president
if the president released his college
and passport records he trump would
donate five million dollars to charity
well actually trump recorded some
alternate challenges that he decided not
to go with at the last minute we were
able to get our hands on these outtakes
we're gonna show them to you with right
now if president obama releases his 10th
grade chemistry final exam
i will hire a homeless person
to wrestle a shark in my name if
president obama releases his fantasy
football lineup from the years 1998
through to and including 2002
i will free one orphan from the cage
complex in my penthouse if president
obama releases his 1967 to 1968 letters
to the tooth fairy in santa claus
i will eat a ball of ugali which is a
popular kenyan porridge if president
obama releases his coveted recipe for
shortbread cookies i will chart an
expedition to the arctic and sleep
inside the holodot carcass of a mastodon
for the month of january